وسط خلافات عميقه بين الجمهورين
والديمقراطيين بشان سقف الديون اجتمع
الرئيس بايدن مع رئيس مجلس النواب في
محاوله جديده لتقريب وجهات النظر والعثور
على اتفاق يجنب البلاد كارثه اقتصاديه
حقيقيه ياتي الاجتماع في ظل مزيد من
التحذيرات الرسميه كتلك التي وردت من مكتب
الميزانيه بالكونجرس والذي ذكر الطرفين
بضروره الاتفاق لان البلاد ربما تتخلف عن
دفع مستحقات ديونها بحلول منتصف الشهر
المقبل والتي بلغت حتى الان واحدا وثلاثين
تريليون دولار فاصل اربعه اذا لم يتم حل
الازمه وبسرعه عقب مغادرته البيت الابيض
اوضح رئيس مجلس النواب كيفن كارثي ان
الخلافات مستمره وانه تم الاتفاق فقط على
الاستمرار في التفاوض
من الممكن التوصل لاتفاق مع نهايه الاسبوع
الحالي الامر ليس صعبا في حاله سابقه في
عهد رؤساء السابقين تمكن السياسيون من
تجاوز خلافاتهم وتم رفع سقف الدين
الامريكي لكن التشاؤم يخيم هذه المره على
معظم المراقبين بواشنطن بسبب تشدد الاعضاء
الجمهوريين الجدد الداعمين لمكارتي بمجلس
الشيوخ ونواب والذين دخلوا الكونغرس في
الانتخابات النصفيه الاخيره بحسابات
مختلفه
هؤلاء الجمهوريون متشددون ولديهم ولاء
لدونالد ترامب وهم يرون ان اي ضرر يمس
الاقتصاد وبايدن يضع ترامب في موقع افضل
اعتقد انهم غير مكترثين بازمه سقف الدين
من اجل اتفاق جديد حول سقف الدين الامريكي
يطالب الجمهوريون الرئيس بيضا الديمقراطي
بخفض برامج الانفاق الحكومي الذي كان وعد
بها الناخبين بنسبه لا تق عن عشرين بالمئه
والا فانهم مستعدون كما يقولون للمضي قدما
في مواقفهم ولو تطلب الامر ركودا اقتصاديا
حتى الان يرفض الرئيس بايدن والديمقراطيون
الردوخ لمطالب الجمهوريين ويعتبرون شروطهم
غير مقبوله لذلك انطلقت لعبه المفاوضات
كما يصفها المراقبون والتي يجب ان تسرع
حسب قولهم لان البلاد لن تكون قادره على
دفع المستحقات الشهر المقبل وستكون
النتائج كارثيه حسبا مختلف التنبؤات لم
تتوقف وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه عن تكرار
التحذيرات الرسميه للسياسيين قبل واثناء
وبعد مفاضات البيت الابيض لكن دون جدوى
دون ان تلقى اجابات حقيقيه هو مريحه من
الجمهوريين المتشددين في مواقفهم حتى الان
ما زالت الوزيره غير قادره حتى الان على
طمانه الامريكيين نصر حسين الجزيره واشنطن